a long time ago a GMC Econoline minivan
in the parking lot of a high school it's
waiting something's about to happen
inside that house where the baby was
made in the no God
inside that High School innocent young
Bob with his innocent young friends are
attending a basketball game we're all
banned kids so we're all in the pep band
sitting in the stands playing chamaleon
playing the fight song I don't remember
what happened to the basketball game we
probably lost we sucked ass but it ends
and we all grow and drop our instruments
off in the band room and now it's time
the van patiently waiting is there it
knows what's about to happen even if we
don't free friends and their three
girlfriends at the time make their way
out to the parking lot we rode together
it's a big van orgy
you're predicting I'm gonna be right
it's not entirely wrong I guess
young high schoolers three couples climb
into the van each one taking their own
row it's a three row man in the middle
and a back we spread out you don't want
to be too close together of course turn
the van on pump some jams but we don't
go anywhere no one's even in the
driver's seat oh in the middle row young
innocent Bob gets to kiss a girl for the
very first time
what is this
girlfriend Saddles up next to him and
then climbs up on his lap and looks
deeply into his eyes and Bob goes in for
a big open mouth kiss because he doesn't
know how it works bang their teeth cling
together like two shields on the field
hold on wait a minute that wasn't how I
thought that was good I thought you made
out with your mouth open no idiot God
geez this guy
anyway once everything gets worked out
Bob and high school girlfriend start
making out as do the other couples what
you do when you're in high school just
six kids in a in a van all just making
out in the high school parking lot like
you do totally normal this moment will
be etched in Bob's memory for the rest
of his life he will never forget what it
was like it's a girl for the first time
it's a weird situation of all the his
other friends all around him everyone
just making out having a great time
going to town and of course the
soundtrack for this defining moment the
song that will never leave that will
Echo for eternity in Bob's mind a true
classic look at this Photograph
every time I do what makes me laugh what
the hell is that seriously though my
first kiss my first I mean that's maybe
not my first like Kiss either pecks on
the cheek or things but that's like my
first making out with a girl ever is
inexorably tied to the song Photograph
by Nickelback I mean I know there's a
lot of Mimi hate for Nickelback on the
internet but I [__] hate that song I
have nothing against Nickelback I think
they do have some bangers they're a fine
band like I don't hate them the way that
a lot of people might on the on the
internet but why is that the song Why
couldn't it have been a good song Why
couldn't it have been like Metallica or
something epic do you not see how
perfect that song was well it's a song
about looking at a photograph and
memories and what are you doing but
remembering that moment yeah to that
song yeah
and now every time the meme on the
internet happens where the the edit
where it's like look at this graph
so hot
way
how freaking out music
is memory
uh